دانت شبكه الجزيره الاعلاميه بشده استهداف
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي سياره تقل
صحفيين فلسطينيين ما ادى لاستشهاد حمزه
الدحدوح ومصطفى ثريا واصابه الصحفي حازم
رجب اصابه بلغه وقالت الجزيره ان اغتيال
الزميلين مصطفى وحمزه يؤكد من جديد ضروره
اتخاذ جميع الاجراءات القانونيه الفوريه
واللازمه في حق قوات الاحتلال لضمان عدم
الافلات من العقاب
واكدت شبكه الجزيره ان اغتيال حمزه
الدحدوح يؤكد بما لا يدع مجالا للشك تصميم
القوات الاسرائيليه على الاستمرار في
الاعتداءات الغاشمه على الصحفيين
وعائلاتهم وذلك بهدف فنم عن اداء مهمتهم
وحثت شبكه الجزيره المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه والحكومات والمنظمات الحقوقيه
والامم المتحده على محاسبه اسرائيل على
جرائمها الشنيعه والمطالبه بانهاء استهداف
وقتل الصحفيين وتعهدت شبكه الجزيره باتخاذ
الاجراءات القانونيه كافه لملاحقه مرتكبي
هذه الجرائم كما اكدت تضامنها ووقوفها الى
جانب جميع الصحفيين في غزه والتزامها دؤوب
بتحقيق العداله لاكثر من 100 صحفي قضوا
قتلا